so i was watching your video about the
uh the casting process on the first
screen movie and how you were
emphasizing that wes believed in you he
gave you your break during that audition
process so i was wondering if that
carried over to filming is there any
example of a time on set where
wes really believed in your creative
instincts and supported something you
wanted to do
oh yeah definitely he
you know i told this story that you know
when i did the rules scenes we had the
first take and he's like all right i got
it let's move on and i was like no no i
was a young actor super insecure you
know i was like did i do enough this is
a huge speech the most i've ever said in
film and he's like well we don't need it
and i was like please
it just kept bugging him and he's like
all right you got another take and then
hit that take
and then he's like do it again just
and he kept it rolling and
we got around film it's not digital
and then afterwards he was like that was
so good he's like never ever question
asking a director for another take he
goes because you really nailed it in
that second third take and
it set me on my way of like always
feeling like i can collaborate which i
probably shouldn't have felt such a
young age
and such was such an icon but he was so
inviting and um
he told me like in the movie it's like
the second third take is what he used so
he loved it so i was very lucky
i have another uh very specific line of
dialogue i want to ask you about you
have a million lines in this movie that
i'll never
i'll never be able to unhear and i can't
imagine anyone else on this planet
delivering the one that always gets me
every time is when you shout everybody
is a suspect in the video stores the
build of that speech is just so spot on
but then it's the intensity of that line
that gets me every time so how many
times do you have to do something on
like that on set before you feel like i
nailed it i got it to like a pitch
perfect level
now that's something i don't remember
how many times we did it we probably did
that like two or three times you know so
as you're doing the wide then you get
your lines better until they go to your
coverage and i don't know if i was first
or second but
i definitely felt like i was probably in
it all day because i was
it was a huge speech and about the whole
video store and walking around and so
i just just it built up to you know this
and this and this and this what are you
talking about prom night let's do this
but
everybody's a suspect so that's what i
felt it should have been and uh he gets
to a crescendo of craziness and i do
think that the audience seemed to
resonate with them
absolutely it most certainly did with me
i also wanted to ask you about the scene
where
uh stu and randy are kind of fighting as
they're trying to convince
sydney to let them in the house because
it's
it's so chaotic and it feels like a
moment that can't be
totally scripted so is that kind of how
it was like for you guys on set was it
chaotic was there the opportunity to
play around with that argument
that was definitely chaotic and
definitely there was lines obviously
scripted but running in and out around
the house who's there boo who what says
no it's not me it's him no no no sydney
no it's him you know that was definitely
you know like you said tense
feverish moment and it was chaotic um
but yeah we definitely got to play
around with it for sure it wasn't just
totally scripted we were in there but it
was definitely not in the script too but
it was
we what would you do in that moment no
no listen no no no no no no he's lying
he's like you know what i mean that was
definitely additive
here's a here's a bigger broader one
because there's not enough time for me
to touch on every single scene of yours
that i love can you give us an example
of one beat in scream that you had a
tougher time nailing that you really had
to work on and then maybe another where
it just clicked right from the start you
did it and you immediately knew i nailed
it
well i definitely felt
i definitely felt good in the video
store
because i felt like that was my first
day and i was super prepared
and i was like that's an early one i
gotta get this out it was a big speech
and i do believe
i think wes laughed
after it so i think okay that was a good
sign
like yo you're so crazy
um you already know about the rules
where i felt pretty good but i was like
unsure
i think the fountain
was more loose but it was more like
i was trying different things you know
like trying to do like jerry lewis and
different stuff like that and
you know eating the nuts and
going back and forth with rose and then
do i eat a seed here or not and i think
that was a little bit more i tried stuff
so
i had a good time filming it but i
didn't know what they were going to use
out of that so that was a little bit
more like i wasn't sure but i had a good
time doing it
all right let's jump to scream two now
so i was also watching your video about
that but
the timeline like does not compute for
me i know you are getting bits and
pieces of the script leading up to it
but
there's just so little time between the
release of scream and scream two so how
long did it take until you actually had
a full script in your hands
oh
scream came out and then i went away i
finished as good as it gets and then i
took a little vacation i think
and then
we were filming by
jewish
late may early june in atlanta so i
probably got a script
march
mid late marches but it wasn't was like
pages and parse script
the red line down the middle and the
number because they didn't want it on
the internet the internet was just
starting to pop off and people were
xeroxing it
are they gonna leak it
was a big deal
so i would say that um
mar i can't remember but because we i
remember we were in atlanta by june
so probably we shot after memorial day
and it was probably
march i got a script which was pretty
quick maybe april maybe even april
so now correct me if i'm wrong but even
at that point you don't know who the
killers and screamed to are and you
didn't know during the table read i
think so when did you find out who was
behind the mask in scream two
i gotten parts of it and then
i'm pretty sure that we didn't have the
ending
at the table read i think only because
they wanted to keep it a secret but also
they were like working it out still
so i think we had like 85 pages i'm not
sure if we had to total any but i always
you know remember that you know sarah
michelle gellar was there when she read
that like she falls off her roof and
she's like ah crap you know and then
like i was reading randy and i had heard
and i'm like he walked in front of a van
meets his untimely demise i'm like oh
crap you know like it was like
damn
so
i think that
we were learning as we went but
definitely i didn't know
laurie metcalf or timothy
[Music]
or cotton where he was coming back i'm
thinking as we go here but i'm
definitely thinking i didn't know so
much of who the killer was i don't
it was rory metcalf right
yeah
laurie lori and uh timothy elephant
i think i didn't know that but i
remember timothy coming in and i'm like
there's something about this dude
that he's got to be but jerry could have
been the red herring you know what i
mean so where's the audience's eyes
yeah right so i i definitely thought tim
timothy had a darkness to him so i think
i wasn't surprised when he was involved
all right what about when you're asked
to come back for scream three was there
any as a hesitation or apprehension
because it wasn't a kevin williamson
script and then what did you think of
your bit when you finally got it
i
i was happy you know to be a part of it
i was bombed that i was killed but i
thought this would be probably the last
movie i really did think that
and i thought well it was a good run and
you know i'm going to be in this movie
and
how cool is it so we went
and i went one day and filmed the whole
day and i had all my
you know videotaped stuff and
i thought that was a really cool way to
put randy in and it was like totally
made sense and it was
uh
completely on par with his character
so i thought like this is great
and then when i filmed that i was a
little bomb so it was only there for a
day you know and everyone was involved
i was like
i wish i could have stayed part of it
but i thought at that point after this
and then they moved the release date not
christmas i think it was february of
2000 and i thought you know
maybe
there was a little bit of fatigue in the
genre
and then it did it took a little break
for a while
but now i think it's going to be hotter
than that
i i'm a big believer that that's going
to be the case yeah yeah but it needed
to go it needed to take a little break
to being reinvigorated in the new cast
well it's a very fair point given what
scream is it's almost like it it needed
uh it needed more material to work with
and to apply to the meta concept to give
it to give it all of like that juiciness
that the previous films have now we have
a whole new crop of horror films for it
to comment on and i think that's
brilliant
totally true you have to live it's like
you can't make new art without
experiencing life so scream had to
experience life to them
consume it and then comment on it
exactly all right now i gotta ask you a
little bit about scream five i watched
trailer reaction as well and quite
enjoyed that so i keep
reading all of these takes and theories
that randy might not be dead and it's
taking everything in me right now not to
blurt out how strongly i feel that that
should not be the case as much as i love
you but what is your take on that would
it just like would you be excited if
randy wasn't dead or is that just not a
good idea you want him dead
i want him dead because i'll never
forget how powerful that death scene was
and how much it broke my heart and i
wouldn't want it to take away from how
good i think that scene is in scream too
so then should other characters be
brought back that are dead wow okay so
you're
i understand you're a super cinephile
zealous
like the rules of the rules or the rules
or the rules or the rules i love what
you're saying
um i think you're right it's like what
rule can you break here you love you
love him so much even more because you
lost him so early in his life in his
career and his rants
so if he became back does it negate what
you felt
um
i
to all purposes i know i'm dead
i'm not involved in screen five i'm
deader than a doornail
and
i was killed in the 90s so
uh
but i agree with what you're saying
and that's interesting but if he did
there are ways he could have come back
or never died or
there's alternate verses there's you
know he faked his death there's all that
type of stuff
but i i believe he's dead
okay okay in
in that legacy lives on his legacy
that's i mean that is a big thing
everything that came after it he appears
in scream three and and conveys the
rules and then others try to kind of
pick up that mantle and scream for there
are characters that are kind of modeled
off of him his legacy will be present
throughout
i think and i think that's what's good
you you take the legacy and you move on
from it absolutely a little a little
predicting here do do you have any uh
ideas of who might be the killer in
scream five especially because there's
there's ties to stu's house there's you
know the tagline it's always someone you
know there are so many things that are
pointing me back to the original right
now
i haven't followed as close as you have
so i don't know enough but that
that's a great tag line it's always
someone you know that's so good because
that's what scream is
in all of the movies
who is the killer in the third one
in the third
scott foley i got feelings about that
one
people get in their feelings about it
some people put four before three
um
yeah you do yeah i do
yeah um
i don't know
i don't know they're saying the stu's
house is there it's in it somebody sent
me a picture and said this blurred out
picture of randy in it somewhere
so
i don't know but it probably is always
someone you know
so
who knows
jamie thank you so much for hanging out
with us i appreciate it thank you perry
i appreciate it appreciate you guys
you